hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about the latest technological
advance
in gene silencing through epigenetic
editing
by using programmable crispr fusion
proteins
and so the advance we'll be talking
about comes from this recent cell paper
that describes what they call crispr off
which is a single fusion protein
that programs heritable epigenetic
memory
now you might be thinking i made a video
on epigenetic editing
just the other week why are we
revisiting it so soon
well this paper shows quite nicely that
this technique has been improved from
earlier studies
and can be used to actually target the
majority of genes within a genome
and is also highly specific also they
show that the
epigenetic editing can be remembered by
the cell
and persists through multiple cell
divisions and so these are some really
great advances that have been made
and they also show that these marks can
be reversed but before we take a look at
these new advances in the technology
i'll begin by addressing what the
problem is that this technology is
trying to solve
and show you how this new technique
compares to previous epigenetic editors
and why this is such an awesome advance
for crispr technology
so let's begin with crisper cast 9. many
of you will probably have heard about
crispr cast 9
and its ability to edit genes and so the
way that this happens is that
the crispr complex which involves the
cas9 protein and a so-called guide rna
is recruited to a specific site on dna
that matches the rna sequence of the
guide rna
so the first concept is you have
programmable targeting to a dna site
and by programmable i mean you can
change the guide rna sequence
to alter the sites that the crispr cas9
complex
recognizes once it's arrived the dna
complex opens up
and this enables the cas9 protein to
induce a double-stranded break into the
dna sequence
there are then two broad consequences
for what then happens with this double
stranded break
if nothing else is introduced into the
cell the cell will try and repair itself
by putting the ends back together and
that can result in insertions or
deletions
more commonly referred to as indels the
alternative approach
refers to precise genome editing
techniques
whereby you introduce along with the
crispr complex a so-called repair
template
that can be used to edit the dna
sequence as the double-stranded break
gets repaired
now there are two main kind of problems
with this system
the first one is that the process
involves the introduction of a
double-stranded break
and many studies now have shown that
double-stringer breaks are very
dangerous for a cell
it basically puts the cell in danger
modes and causes it to
stop the fighting upregulate my favorite
protein p53
and try and deal with this damage and
that can have undesirable consequences
and so this leads me on to the second
problem which is the fact that
these mechanisms of gene editing or gene
disruption
depends upon the cell's internal
mechanism
to be able to repair this
double-stranded break so but depending
on the cells here
so it's to some extent unpredictable
what could happen
because as much as we like to understand
these cells and say that we understand
them
they do have a mind of their own well
not really we know what i mean
and so advances have already been made
to try and avoid some of these problems
namely advances such as base editing and
prime editing
to perform precise genome editing
without having double stranded breaks
but in terms of inducing indels so
trying to disrupt expression of a gene
the only current alternatives involve
not inducing double-stranded brakes
but to instead fuse the cas9 protein to
other proteins that can influence the
surrounding landscape
of the gene to manipulate gene
expression
now that might sound a bit confusing but
it's probably the most important thing
to understand
before i go any further you see
sometimes we don't want to actually
change the dna sequence
we just want to alter the expression
levels of a gene
and expressing a gene is a very
complicated process
and is tightly controlled within a cell
and so cells have
epigenetic marks that are used to help
regulate the expression of different
genes
and this is because different epigenetic
marks can be read by the cell
to indicate gene expression or not and
also
epigenetic marks can influence the
packaging of the dna
and influence how accessible the region
is to different
so-called transcription factors that
actually carry out the gene expression
and so to summarize that more succinctly
to avoid the use of double-stranded
breaks
instead of altering the dna sequence it
will hypothesize
that altering epigenetic marks or what
proteins are brought into proximity of
the gene
is an alternative strategy to influence
gene expression
without changing the underlying dna
sequence
and so as i kind of just alluded to
there are two main ways in which you can
alter
gene expression by having cas9 fused to
different proteins
the first one is to fuse cast 9 to
different enzymatic proteins that can
actually
mediate the different epigenetic marks
so you could fuse it to a protein that
can remove methylation
from dna or the histamine proteins that
dna is wrapped around to form chromatin
in the nucleus or you can fuse the cas9
protein to different domains
that interact with some of the
transcriptional machinery such as
the rna polymerase protein that actually
carries out
transcription which is the first step of
gene expression
and so i actually made two separate
videos that go into a bit more detail
if you wanted it regarding these two
different strategies
because this paper this crisper off
technique kind of takes stir them
together to make one super effective
gene inhibiting machine and this is
because
whilst these epigenetic editing crispr
complexes
can solve the problem of not inducing
double-stranded breaks
as well as circumventing the uncertainty
with how that double-stranded break is
repaired by the cell
it faces another problem which is that
the
dna sequence isn't altered and so if
that cell divides
is the epigenetic manipulation also
going to be inherited
or is it just going to be a transient
change in gene expression
and the second issue is understanding
how many different genes can be targeted
by using such an approach
as the more sites that can be targeted
the more effective the tool
so let's now take a look at their
christopher off approach
and so remember as kind of suggested by
the name the idea here is to be able to
silence
gene expression so if we look at their
first two versions of crispr off
we can see here the dead cast 9 protein
and so dead cast 9 refers to the cast 9
protein that's been mutated
so that it can no longer induce any
double-stranded breaks into the dna
sequence
but it retains that programmable dna
binding activity
so you can still recruit it to sites of
interest and so that's pretty
important for these techniques to work
but you can see
in addition to having this dead cast 9
protein there's something called crab
at one side and there's something called
dnmt3a the other side
and also 3l and so the crab domain has
previously been used alone
as you can see above here to be able to
silence gene expression
and this approach has been referred to
as crispr eye for crispr interference
whilst the dnmt3a and 3l refer to
dna methyltransferase proteins that can
add
methylation marks to dna and so these
domains are
altering the epigenetic marks whilst the
crab domain is influencing what proteins
are recruited
into the proximity of the gene and so in
a way it's combining previous approaches
together
but is it actually more effective well
as you can see in this figure here
they compared their crisper off version
one to these two alternative approaches
used alone and what's plotted is the
percentage of cells
that have lost expression of gfp which
was their testing gene post-introduction
of these crispr complexes and what you
can see
is that crisp off achieved a much more
effective silencing of this gfp gene
than the two alternative approaches and
so it actually turned out that version 2
was more effective than version 1 as you
can see in the second figure
but what's more interesting to note
about this figure is that here you can
see that they only transiently expressed
the crispr of system yet 50 days post
transfection of this complex and so the
dashed line actually indicates
when the crispr system will no longer be
expressed in the cell
you can still see durable memory of this
gene silencing and over 90 percent of
the cells
and actually they observe that this
memory can be remembered after 15 months
this time by targeting a different gene
clta
and so you can see here that 38 out of
39 different clones
maintained the silencing importantly
they also showed in this study
that crispr off is very specific so
basically it means that
it's targeting the gene that they want
to target and not implicating
the expression of other genes and so you
can do that by performing rna sequencing
to see how the expression levels of the
different genes vary
on introduction of crisp or off and so
you can see in these different graphs
here
that the only gene that seems to be
significantly different
in terms of expression level is the gene
that they were targeting by crispr off
so in these cases itgb1 cd81
and cd151 but how general is this
approach
can it be applied to any gene of
interest well they also tested this
and they did this by performing a
crisper off screen
whereby they targeted the crisper of
complex and different cells to
more than 20 000 different genes and so
obviously some genes within a cell are
essential for that cell to grow
and so by reducing their expression they
are not going to be able to grow
properly
and so you can use gray phenotype to
assess the efficacy
in terms of the silencing of gene
expression and so as expected cells that
didn't grow as well
had the crispr off targeting genes
involved in processes such as cell
proliferation
and so this helped to validate that
crispr off
was working out many different gene
sites
but obviously if you were going to
target a specific gene it'd be
worthwhile
optimizing chris but off to work for
that gene
anyway so far crisproff is shown to be
heritable and pass on to different cells
and it doesn't alter the genome sequence
or introduce double strand breaks
which are all desirable for this crispr
editing tool
but another reason why epigenetic
editing is so desirable is because these
marks
can be removed and so in this paper they
also
look to see whether or not the gene
silencing that they had introduced into
the cells
could be reversed so to do that they
designed a different tool
this time they called it crispr on
obviously because now we want to switch
back on the gene expression
and so to do that we can use the same
toolkit that we've discussed before
using epigenetic modifiers and different
protein domains that
interact with the transcriptional
machinery to this time
activate gene expression instead of
silencing it so their crispr on tool
involves
a dna d-methylase so removing those
methylation groups that were added by
crispr off
and also to make this tool more
effective they use protein domains that
are known to interact with
transcriptional cofactors to promote
gene expression
another thing to think about with these
tools is what cell types can it be used
for
because different cell types are easier
to target than others
notably neurons are quite hard to target
and so
what was quite cool about this study is
that they applied crispr off
to stem cells that they then
differentiated into neurons
but before the differentiation they also
introduced crispr off
to target the gene that encodes the tau
protein that is implicated in many
different
neurological diseases such as
alzheimer's disease
and what they found was that even though
this crispr off was only transiently
introduced
to target the tal gene at later stages
of the differentiation protocol
they found that the tau protein levels
were still reduced in around 30 percent
of the cells and so this is kind of
interesting data
and very exciting because it gives hope
that
there's the ability to rewrite gene
expression
in cells derived from induced
pluripotent stem cells
to modulate gene expression and cell
types that are typically quite
challenging to target
in terms of delivery of the crispr
complexes and so to summarize
this paper introduces crispr off and
crisper on
two technologies for programmably
writing and erasing epigenetic memories
to control gene expression programs and
in particular the study mainly focuses
on crispr off
which they demonstrate that with only
transient expression
it was able to write a robust specific
and multiplexable gene silencing program
that is memorized by the cells through
multiple cell divisions
and differentiation and importantly it
could be rapidly reversed by using
crispr on
so in addition to the fact that chris
but off was able to silence
the majority of human genes these new
technologies are very promising and very
exciting
in terms of what we can further do with
them in terms of
further understanding our awesome cells
but also in terms of potential
therapeutic applications
so i'm pretty excited to see what
further work has done using these tools
in the future
so with that i hope you were able to
follow whatever i said in this video
and that you were able to learn
something from it and with that i'd like
to thank my patreon supporters
and to thank you for listening